foreign
[Music]
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
tonight on Facebook announced that it's
a scandal that's rocked the royal family
racially charged comments made to a
charity worker for the top Palestine to
resign
Prince William tonight attacks his own
godmother for offensive remarks Lady
Susan Hussey has apologized and quit was
she a bad apple or does it signify a
deeper malaise at the pants
last disgrace Matt Hancock returns from
Australian jungle I can't confirm that I
bumped into him a Heathrow but should
the public be buying his new Mr Nice Guy
act his jungle co-star Scarlett Douglas
joins me live and is not a fan
[Music]
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
it seems only yesterday I was in Qatar
it was only yesterday that was actually
at 2 A.M this morning so there we are
the wonders of modern travel welcome to
Piers Morgan and sense that it's become
very fashionable recent years to smear
the British Monarchy as racist it's the
age of white privilege today's Royals
must atone the colonial sins are out of
touch Beyond reform they should be
abolished and embark on endless
groveling apology tour for the terrible
ancestors I find most of that complete
nonsense the monarchy is mostly a reason
for immense national pride they
represent us with distinction and
dignity to the world that's why when the
queen died the whole world stopped still
for 10 days to pay homage to her and
what she's done for
but there is a duty I think for everyone
at the Royal household from the top down
to be responsible about the positions
they hold and sometimes they let us down
last night Camilla the Queen the new
Queen hosted a reception on domestic
violence at Buckingham Palace well Lady
Susan Hussey Prince William's godmother
and was one of the Queen's closest Queen
Elizabeth's closest aides for many many
decades
made racially charged comments to the
head of a domestic abuse charity in
Josie Fulani the woman she spoke to
released a transcript of what she says
as a conversation they had we've had it
voiced by producers
where are you from Sister space no where
do you come from We're based in Hackney
no what part of Africa are you from I
don't know they didn't leave any records
well you must know where you're from I
spent time in France where are you from
here UK no but what nationality are you
I am born here and I'm British no but
where do you really come from where do
your people come from my people lady
what is this oh I can see I'm going to
have a challenge getting you to say
where you're from when did you first
come here lady I am a British national
my parents came here in the 50s when oh
I knew we'd get there in the end your
Caribbean no lady I'm of African
Heritage Caribbean descent and British
nationality
well let me be very clear those comments
in today's age I'm afraid are shocking
they crass they're offensive they're
racist
that's why Lady Hussey is now rightly
resigned the palace says the comments
are unacceptable they've quickly fronted
up to this Scandal for that they deserve
credit this won't go away in a hurry it
will be Grist to the mill for those who
want to trash the monarchy and Brandi a
racist institution the timing could
hardly be worse next week the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex will be ludicrously
given a human rights award for fighting
racism in the royal family it was Megan
of course who infamously smeared the
monarchy's racist in her Oprah Winfrey
wineathon Megan has never produced any
evidence tandem the conversation of he
won't be given security he's not going
to be given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
well Meg has never given any hard
evidence to back up any of her racism
claims but mud sticks the damage was
done and this Scandal will undoubtedly
fuel those who think that there was
Merit to what she said
now what's been going on today by
coincidence is that Prince William and
the Princess of Wales have been in the
United States in Boston for a three-day
tour and that will now be completely
overshadowed by this new race storm back
in London I think that's why he took the
unusual step today of attacking lady
Hussey remember his own godmother
directly racism has no place in society
William spokesman said these comments
were unacceptable and it's right that
the individual stepped aside with
immediate effect that individual is his
own godmother
and make no mistake she wasn't a minor
background figure at the palace lady
Hussey was the late Queen's most loyal
lady and waiting for I think five or six
decades
she Stood Beside the new Queen Camilla
on state occasions and it will raise
uncomfortable questions about how
somebody in her position could possibly
be so stupid
after Megan's original baseless claims
Prince William said categorically
they're all family is not a racist
family and I believe him I also believe
the monarchy is a powerful unifying
force in our country but in this year of
transition with all eyes on King Charles
of the coronation coming and inevitable
questions about the future of the
monarchy has to do better than this
nobody capable of such witness and
offensive comments should be in the
Royal household and it's right lady
Hussey has gone
but there should also now be a fool I
think investigation to see if anybody
else in that household shares similar
sentiments and Views because if they do
they shouldn't be there well joining me
now is former BBC World correspondent
Michael Cole and the organizer of black
lives matter protests Imam eight welcome
to both of you
um
Michael Cole
if someone said to me today look she's
in her 80s there is a generational
aspect of this where people of her age
might ask questions which sound wrong
and I can understand a little bit that
that might be the case and maybe it is a
bit generational it doesn't mean it's
not offensive or crass or frankly racist
I mean for a black woman to be invited
to the palace and be subjected to this
bizarre interrogation
persistently demanding to know where she
was from when she was born in this
country and is a British citizen is
completely outrageous and the most
terrible thing peers of course is that
the focus is now not on domestic
violence and eradication of that which
is most important it's on this incident
it's all terrible and it's very sad but
as you've said lazy Susan Hussey is 83
she's a widow she was married to Mama
June Cassie who calls ran the BBC was
the chairman of the BBC for indeed
indeed and we through the massive Bashir
episode and we knew him very well and do
you know Lady Susan I do well I kind of
woman is she well I've seen her around
the world when she was the head girl as
you so rightly say to her majesty the
queen in all sorts of uh situations with
different people from different
backgrounds different ethnicity and she
was always charming and very kind and
very nice now what we don't have
is a recording of that we have a
transcript of somebody's remembrance of
that conversation but we do know an
investigation was very quickly commenced
and we do know the result is she has
immediately been let go now exactly and
she apologized immediately so there's no
denial of it no no no there is none she
apologized and she's resigned and let's
be honest about it nobody actually died
nobody was killed on this occasion
it is offensive it shouldn't have
happened and remedies have been taken
and I feel sorry for her I've got uh you
know I knew her quite well I never saw
her act other than properly but you
always put people at ease what she
didn't learn is what the queen always
learned when she was a situation like
this with people she didn't know she
would always say have you come far now
that is a very good question because
nobody can take it all right let me go
to Iman here look Michael's putting a
sort of nice gloss on this but if I'm a
black woman
and I've gone to the Palace particularly
for a charity event like that and I've
done so much good work as in gozi Fulani
has done with your sister space
organization and acne you know just for
those who don't know what it is it's a
group that supports African and
Caribbean women affected by domestic and
sexual abuse so to be there and to be so
belittled by a very Posh older white
lady who's been working at the palace
for six decades to be belittled in that
way and to be constantly challenged
about where you're really from with all
the racist undertones of when you can't
be one of us you clearly come from
somewhere else
I find that offensive and I'm a white
man
absolutely offensive so I'm very glad
that you both agree
um so what this example is covert racism
so
um it's basically code about racism in
the form of a micro invalidation so when
someone comes along and says where are
you from no no no where are you really
from what they're inferring is that that
person couldn't possibly as a black
woman have you had this experience every
day how does it make you feel when it
happens to you
utterly ignored I feel offended I feel
dismissed and I feel as if I've been put
into this kind of box where I'm not seen
nor am I heard and I'm just expected to
just go along with this kind of
narrative which is okay to perpetuate
racism throughout the day so for me
personally it's an experience that most
black people I can confidently say
experience on a day-to-day basis do you
give any did you give any slack to her
age that it's a generational thing that
that generation may not have even
realized that asking somebody questions
like that is racist
um I take that into consideration but it
doesn't negate the fact that that seems
to stem throughout many generations and
therefore we cannot take away the fact
that covert racism is prevalent within
our society irrespective of your age
Michael what's extraordinary to me is
we've just been through the whole Megan
and Harry Oprah racism
say there will be people there are
already on Twitter saying she's been
Vindicated this is what she was talking
about the subliminal racism that is
laced through the palace hard to argue
that now I would argue the difference is
here we had a name somebody did
something and the victim of this put a
tweet out using the initials sh and said
it was a lady it was only one of those
in the palace so we knew who she was
talking about and that person has been
made accountable my issue with Megan and
Harry from the start of their racism
claims is there's never been any hard
evidence put forward nor have they named
who they who they believe was racist
therefore everyone is Guilty By
Association so they are to me different
things but there is no doubt this will
lend sucker to their argument as they
stand on this stage at the Robert F
Kennedy Foundation next week for their
heroism in tackling racism at the palace
there's no doubt they will use this to
fuel their position and that's very much
why Buckingham Palace moved Swift and
Prince William moves swiftly to distance
himself for it really really pretty
amazing I mean you're pretty in context
that woman's his godmother yeah she was
one of the Queen's closest if not the
closest Confidant of the queen for 60
years absolutely this is not just anyone
at the back well as her her godson can't
stand up for her I'll have to stand up
for ladies Susan and say that I'm sure
there was no malice intended everybody
was wearing name pads
perhaps she saw the name which was of
course unusual to her and perhaps she
was genuinely trying to find out a
little bit about where she came from
it's quite a normal thing for people to
say have you come far have you been this
way around but I understand why the
palace you know racism is absolutely
toxic the terrible thing about the
charge of racism is it's easy to make
and it's almost impossible in this case
you see I think it's a clear open and
sharp case I mean I agree with what you
just said but I also think that black
people in this country will all look at
this incident everyone who is black in
this country well look at what's
happened here and they'll all be able to
cite similar instances where people have
said where are you from and not really
wanting to think they're British like we
white people and that is the damaging
thing about this episode is that you've
got somebody at the heart of the palace
for so long so close to the queen so
close to all of them William's godmother
right I mean that's where I think if I'm
in your position you know representing a
community looking at this going yeah a
we've all been through this and B wow
wow that's somebody quite senior
Buckingham Palace doing it yes and I
think I have to add the fact that it's a
double kind of slap in the face for a
lot of black people because ultimately
this event took place where Camilla
Queen Camilla made a speech that was
focused on domestic violence and she
made it quite clear we need to firstly
she said that it was a heinous crime
secondly she said that we need to
support and listen to survivors and
thirdly we need to believe their stories
now racism is just as heinous as
domestic violence right they manifest
themselves in more or less the exact
same way from ranging from psychological
to physical so the reality is that we
seem to have this uh notion of
supporting and believing and
understanding and listening to those of
domestic Finance to black people yeah we
end up gaslighting which is basically
another form of racism so we find more
racism let me throw a slice let me throw
a slight thing back at your on that
General principle I I have a problem
with believing everyone just when they
come forward with any allegation it may
be the cynical journalist in me but I
believe everyone should be listened to
everyone should be taken seriously but
they're not automatically victims until
something is proven because a lot of
people I'm afraid in modern society they
invent stories they have reasons to scam
you know to Media whatever it may be for
whatever reason
and certainly percentage-wise probably
not a vast percentage but there are
people that will do it so I believe you
listen you take seriously you show
respect a claimant he's making
allegations but I don't think whether
it's racism or violence or whatever it
may be you don't automatically believe
people and I actually the moment you do
that I automatically condemning and
convicting the people they're accusing
who have not had a chance to put their
case forward and it may be they're
completely Innocent but what you first
need to do is listen and ultimately
believe because this is why it comes but
you agree with the sort of principle I'm
making that's what I do it totally
utterly agree with you but what it comes
down to is a fine line you see because
when you ultimately and I said it the
last time I was here when an individual
ignores and the gates or neglects the
thoughts feelings and experiences of
those from the black and brown Community
when pertaining to racism what you're
ultimately doing is invalidating their
experiences which is a form of racism
this is a typical thing that we see and
this is the issue that what I typically
find when it comes down to racism it is
a form of gaslighting that seems to be
the typical Let's ignore that but we're
not
I think this whole we've got into a
place in society now where people can
talk about my truth as if somehow that's
different to the truth and I've got a
big problem with that whoever it is
because to me there's the truth which is
supported by facts and if you have your
own version of it it's not actually the
truth I mean you can feel it and you can
want it to be true but actually facts
should always be sacred because
otherwise I'm not sure where you go if
everyone has their own version of the
truth but Michael it is it seems to me
there's an another bigger issue which
I'm about to come through with another
guest in a minute
we now have William and Kate in Boston
for three days this is supposed to be
the big coming out of the new Prince and
Princess of Wales in America you've got
Megan and Harry in California about to
go to New York to receive this Robert F
Kennedy Foundation which I think is
ludicrous for their heroism in combating
racism at the palace that's not why they
left they left because they wanted to do
their own thing as a royal cake and eat
it and make gazillions out of Netflix we
all know that documentary is coming out
very soon and we'll all see it as is the
book and you've chosen to ignore exactly
what she said about her experiences
thoughts and feelings no no okay let's
throw that in with you just throw that
in I don't know you can say that please
I will refer The Honorable lady to the
answer I gave some moments ago which was
actually she needs to come out they both
do and say who it was that expressed the
concern about the skin color of their
child I agree because the other
allegation they made that Archie was not
a prince because of his skin color was
very quickly discounted they just got
that wrong it doesn't have to do with
his skin color every everything to do
with the order that things go in in the
palace so it's only down to that one
charge left which is that someone in the
royal family expressed concern about the
skin color of their child and she said
it happened at a certain time Harry then
said it happened a year and a half
earlier they couldn't even work out what
year it happened and we've never had a
name unlike here because they think they
haven't because it's out of respect the
same respected yeah
and that's why they won't give out that
I think they've shown unbelievable
disrespect for the role because of
stating they have a few experiences
that's disrespectful they've milked
their attacks on the royal family to the
tune
I'm genuinely curious because you're
saying milk and so all of these things
again I'm just throwing it back at you
what you're what it appears to be is you
are ultimately gaslighting Megan and
Harry no no yes
I'm asking I'm responding I'm directly
calling them out I'm saying that they
are they what they've done they have
taken their role titles from an
institution they profess to dislike
they've taken them to America and they
are fleecing them for massive personal
commercial gain I think it's completely
yeah I think it's completely outrageous
self-awareness self-awareness yes
and racial Prejudice institutions you
don't think that that has anything to do
with that with their motion to Hold Your
Fire because I'm enjoying this that's a
good debate thank you wait a moment save
both of you when I come back after the
break and we're going to debate this and
also talk about what's about to happen
in America
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
guess who's got a brand new show on top
TV at nine o'clock Friday nights live
honestly I don't care I'm a bit rude why
just a bit of fun Friday night's live oh
I will be honest with you I'm not too
honest the criticize was so bad come on
Cristiano give it a chance we're going
in why is it not gonna work tell me you
have to be charismatic yeah well people
have to to feel some connection with you
to be good looking helps too all right
cheeky football bloody hell Friday at
9pm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
I'm Tom Newton Dan join me on first
edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today first edition is about making
sense of what's really going on in
politics on the economy and across the
World At Large music makes sense
opinions that matter so don't miss first
edition with me Tom Newton Dunn each
week night at 10 P.M
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back to Pittsburgh some sad
breaking news has just come in that
Christine McVie uh one of the founder
members of the great band Fleetwood Mac
has died at the age of 79. she was a
wonderful British singer-songwriter
wrote hits like little lies everywhere
don't stop say you love me Songbird she
left the band after 28 years in 1998
returned in 2014 and there's a statement
from Fleetwood Mac there are no words to
describe our sadness at the passing of
Christine V she was truly One of a Kind
special and talented beyond measure she
was the best musician anyone could have
in their band and the best friend anyone
could have in their life we were so
lucky to have a life with her
individually and together we cherished
Christine deeply and are thankful for
the amazing memories we have she will be
so very missed Christine McVie from
Fleetwood Mac one of the Great British
singer-songwriters sad news tonight
well we were talking before the break
about this big Royal race rail which is
erupted with one of the most senior
members of the royal household having to
resign after making racially charged
comment to a black charity worker at the
palace yesterday was all coincides with
the new Prince and princesses of wales's
trip to America to Boston to be more
precise this is their first trip there
for eight years and well it's all going
up in scandalous smoke uh right at the
moment that the Dugan Duchess of Sussex
have got their new Netflix series
premiering We Believe next week well
Michael and Iman are still with me here
plus I'm joined Now by author and
journalist Maureen Allen from the Daily
Mail only things that the cambridges may
have taken them a trip to take on their
Rivals from Montecito so Maureen welcome
to Piers Morgan uncensored again great
to have you
um there's a lot going on in your
country involving our Royals we've got
the the Rival princes now on the same
American soil albeit separated by a few
thousand miles at the moment but what
are you making of all this and in
particular you've got Megan and Harry
next week getting this Awards in the
Robert F Kennedy foundation for the
heroic battle against racism at the
palace and right here is a gift isn't it
where you have a senior member of the
household who has basically been pretty
racist in the way that she spoke to a
black woman at the palace yesterday
agreed no question about it no debate
about it however
if you look at the reception that
William and Kate are getting in Boston
and the level of dignitaries who are
welcoming them with open arms you have
in Boston Caroline Kennedy
the flame keeper really of the entire
Kennedy Legacy such as it is
hosting William and Kate and hosting
this Earth shot Awards you know giving
the families imprimatur as you as it
were and then you have a few days later
Harry and Megan who are going to go to
New York and accept a vague humanitarian
award from the RFK human rights
Foundation which I defy anyone to tell
me one single thing this organization
has done for human rights in the past
say five years
being emceded by none other than Alec
Baldwin I mean that's something who shot
and killed a co-worker yeah and has
since said many times he is not sorry
and he's not the one who did it you know
you couldn't make this up and I think
you're going to see in the coming days
you know the way that the palace and the
way that William and Charles handled
this so swiftly and so unequivocally uh
I think this is going to recede I don't
think anybody truly believes that
William and Kate are upholding some sort
of racist who is more popular Maureen in
America now I mean have Megan and Harry
managed to build a new celebrity
lifestyle there which is now resonating
particularly with younger people perhaps
the more woke members of the community
uh or are the as we call them the top
dogs really who were the The Heirs the
king now and the heir to the throne in
in the pecking order of the royal family
it's very much Charles and Camilla
William and Kate are they seem to be on
a higher level by mayor Americans or not
I get this question all the time and I I
feel as though
um you and Britain don't believe that we
in America see through Harry and Megan
uh
we do I can assure you the special
relationship continues
unmolested trust me but uh no I mean we
we've all we've all had this sort of
Awakening where you know as you said
with the Oprah interview nothing added
up you know there were so many
inconsistencies and so many wild and
vile accusations being flung uh and and
none of it's really stood up you know
nobody wanted them to fail but I also
think in America witnessing the true
outpouring the true sustained outpouring
of grief at the Queen's passing you know
we I think have come to have a new
understanding of of what the monarchy
means to Modern Britain and I think that
in that in that sense Charles and
William are are held in Fairly high
regard right Maureen thank you very much
indeed for giving me that perspective
from across the pond let's come back to
to Michael for a moment there's another
story this week which was a senior
policeman uh Neil bazook came forward
and said that Megan Markle in particular
had been the subject of a lot of very
serious threats against her life by far
right uh terrorists let's call them what
they are in this Junction it was a
rising problem and that is a concern and
may have been one of the reasons I guess
that they felt they should leave the
country although I would say I'm not
sure you're any safer in America which
also has a lot of far-right people
making a lot of threats nor do I think
the rest of the royal family are not
constantly given threats as well so it's
hard to know quite how you calculate all
that but certainly in her case a lot of
it was apparently racially motivated
absolutely appalling apparently these
threats were so vile that they they
couldn't even be articulated by by those
who were describing them but if I may
just Backtrack on what the lady from the
Daily Mail was saying whatever William
and Kate do or Megan and Harry do it
will have no comparison whatsoever with
the last Princess of Wales when she
arrived for the first time she'd never
been to America before November this
month 85 and she came into Washington DC
I was there she was the very height of
her Fame and her glamor she danced at
the White House I have a brilliant story
about this okay well so when will it
when William was last in New York yeah I
happened to be staying in the same Hotel
well wow and I every time they were
using it must have been the car live it
was the Carlisle and every time every
time
very lovely hotel and every time they
use the elevators everybody else got
roped off including mere mortals like me
to my deep irritation so you'd have to
wait for the Royal party to come in get
in the lift go up and whatever and I
found myself trapped behind the Rope one
day with Tom Selleck Magnum we are my
goodness this is one of the all-time
great clanging uh uh anecdotes and we
got talking anyway long story short and
the relevance of me jumping in there he
was at that ball uh with when she danced
with Travolta and in fact he said
well and also Clint Eastwood and Tom
Selleck and the president the president
so Diana was dancing with Clint Eastwood
and Tom said I had my great moment I
went up and I tapped him on the shoulder
which is the time on at a Convention of
move over son she's with the magnet and
he said I then started dancing with her
he said and can you believe it I get a
tap on the shoulder a minute later and I
turn around into my utter horror it's
John Travolta at the height of his
glorious International Fame from
Saturday Night Fever and he said the
next thing he's whisking around like his
character in telling like fever and it
was the most humiliating tap off he
never had well let me just so there you
go no no just a little a little anecdote
because after that wonderful she was
wearing this Victor Edelstein midnight
blue velvet gown she was wonderful the
next morning there was a press
conference at the National Gallery and
they said to the hacks like me they said
the princess is going to be here but
she's not allowed to speak and she won't
speak and you mustn't ask about her
dancing with Travolta obviously this was
absurd it was a press conference for the
press to answer questions so I stood up
and I said could I ask this is through
Prince Charles I say could I could I ask
you your Royal Highness how the princess
is enjoying her first visit to America
and in particular how she enjoyed
dancing with John Travolta last night
the prince was livid he gave his puff
Links of big seeing too and he said well
I'm not her glove puppet yes he said but
I think she she enjoyed it didn't you
and she embarrassedly nodded her head
well why on Earth couldn't they have
leather say so and of course it was that
moment you know why because because
Charles was livid that somebody slinked
his wife around the dance floor and it
was John Travolta better than he could I
don't think I don't like John's of all
of dancing with my wife to be honest
with you
um thank you both very much pretty good
debate as always I appreciate know
coming up next so this morning I flew
back in from Qatar to Heathrow Terminal
4. I was walking out to my car when who
should I spot lurking right next to me
literally my Hancock who'd flown in from
Australia from the jungle to play some
music the conversation went something
like this ah Mr anchor ah Mr Morgan oh I
said I spent the last few weeks giving
you an absolute kicking he said yes I
know it was as my sons would call it
hashtag Orcs uh anyway we're gonna
debate after the break whether he should
be enjoying now Fame and Fortune as a
celebrity this former Camp mate Scarlett
Douglas of talent agent Jonathan shut it
they'll join me next afternoon
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
guess she's got a brand new show on
talktv at nine o'clock Friday nights
live honestly I don't care I'm a bit
rude why just a bit of fun Friday
night's live I I will be honest with you
I'm not too honest the criticize was so
bad come on Cristiano give it a chance
we're going then why is it not gonna
work tell me you have to be charismatic
yeah well people have to to feel some
connection with you to be good looking
helps too all right cheeky football
bloody hell Friday at 9pm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today
first edition is about making sense of
what's really going on in politics on
the economy and across the World At
Large music makes sense opinions that
matter so don't miss first edition with
me Tom Newton Dunn each week night at 10
P.M
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
oh my God
yeah we've seen that group before
haven't we uh that was the moment that
our disgraced former Health secretary
came third on I'm a celebrity get me out
of here
or reminded us all of course of why he
had to lead government breaking his own
lockdown rules with that same lady
ending up on the front page of the Sun
what do you flew back to Heathrow this
morning where I literally bumped into
him and we'll be a little chat uh it was
not entirely uncivilized it was very
British I said I've been giving you a
good kicking the last few weeks about
what he'd done because I have and he
said he knew and that was fine
um but it was interesting he had a
little spring in his step like he's now
moved on he's now a celebrity not a
politician even though he's actually
paid 85 000 pounds a year to represent
his constituents in West Sussex uh
actually he's no longer that he's a guy
who munches kangaroo testicles has
become famous off the back of it to
millions of people who voted for him
staggeringly so should he be allowed to
do all this should he be entitled now to
become a famous celebrity cashing in on
all his infamy well I'm joined Now by
Scarlet Douglas who was in the jungle
with him and my top a talent agent
Jonathan let me start with you Scarlet
you were in there with him and can
barely conceal your disgust as your
feelings changed at all given that the
public appears to have had a joint
lobotomized morphing into Hell by voting
for him in vast numbers
I mean it was a surprise I think for
everybody that he came third But
ultimately with this show you have to do
the best for the camp you've got to win
as many stars as possible you've got to
make sure that you're civil with
everybody you don't have to make sure
but it makes things a lot easier so
actually him coming into the jungle we
were very dubious at first but he became
part of the team and a part of the
family and that's what was most
important for us but what do you think
of him should he be allowed to be doing
any of us at all
well listen everybody's got their own
opinion and their own views on it but
I'm not the talent Booker and obviously
that was down to ITV and they believe
that he would be right for the show
um there obviously was quite a lot of
controversy and when he came in us as
the campmates were quite shocked that he
was there but ultimately we couldn't do
anything about it it wasn't our decision
so we just had to ride that wave and
get on with it as best we could sounds
like you've almost forgiven him
us as camp or yeah
I mean listen for me the minute he came
in I remember sleeping on it and the
next day I had to speak to him and say
ultimately in Camp we are a family and
we are a team and we have to do the best
we can in Camp outside of Camp whether
or not we're going to be friends I
really don't know but here we work
together and that's what's most
important so have I forgiven him I'm not
sure if I'm honest we really didn't get
a chance to know the real Matt in the
jungle we're being filmed 24 7 and
everybody honestly I think he was I
think
I think he was scamming all of you like
he was scamming the public this is a big
Rehabilitation exercise bringing
Jonathan shall it Jonathan you're a top
talent agent would you take on Matt
Hancock now as a client
well it's not really a question at the
moment he's an MP so I don't take on M
Peter's client so I can't speak for the
future but certainly not now and I think
uh you know as I understand it Matt's
remaining an MP so it's not even a
conversation
right but look I mean look I've got a
problem with this not with him
personally you know I've never had a
problem with with him personally I don't
know him that well but he's always you
know when I've done interviews they've
always been a bit fractious but he's
been fine with me personally about it my
problem is the principle of a serving MP
taking a month out to go and Munch
kangaroo testicles in a jungle making
400 000 quid and he's done another
reality show the celebrity SAS thing on
channel four and he's planning a book
and I'm thinking well hang on when's he
finding time to do his job as an MP and
by the way when did we reward people who
were shamed at a government for breaking
their own pandemic lockdown rules and
what about the inquiry which still
hasn't happened yet into all the
damaging mistakes he made as hell
secretary which many think led to
thousands of people dying
well first of all I'm a leading
challenge agent I don't run the British
political system but I shall try and
answer some of that you do a lot better
than most Hancock doing the jungle
probably and I've been asked but I
certainly will stay doing whatever hello
Mighty I'm on television this is my
friend I'm with Piers Morgan Live to the
United States
[Music]
just said he said hello to you he's
Elijah to meet you come here you
subscribe to Missy on YouTube
sorry guys guys
guys you've got it you've had your
moments of Fame come on
that's yours rather enjoying that go
back to them
um Jonathan being mobbed
they were here the second I said just to
explain to us you're actually the bigger
issue well hang on just to explain to
viewers you're both at the same event
the mobo Awards you've both very kindly
come out to speak to us on Piers Morgan
and say so we appreciate it but it is
live TV and there are lots of people
around there presumably waiting to see
stars coming and going from the awards
so that's what's been going on
yes we're at the MOBA awards at Wembley
Arena at the moment and your cameras
have got me in one place and Scarlett
another to make it look like we're in
different places but the truth is we're
actually 50 feet from each other
Don't Kill the Magic no one needs to
know that sausage gets made but Jonathan
on a serious point the serious Point
really is
should an MP be allowed to do all this
well I would question you're absolutely
right there peers I would question
whether an MP this applies to any MP not
not just Matt Hancock should the rules
of parliament allow an MP to go and have
a second job that takes them away from
their constituents for a long time the
answer is probably not but many MPS have
done it so I don't think it's fair to
focus on Matt Hancock because he's
merely doing what you remember George
Galloway doing doing Celebrity Big
Brother when he was pretended he was a
cat many years ago and Nadine Doris and
then another MP did the splash so
there's a history of MPS but you know
they feel the way they can talk to the
most people is by doing a show like this
and I have to say to be fair to Matt
Hancock a lot of people will be
interested to hear what he has to say in
the months to come because he's done
this show Intelligence Jonathan
I would rather he comes on my show and
face his proper forensic examination of
all the things that have led to this
point in his career because there are
some serious questions I'd love to ask
him which he has repeatedly done we keep
asking him he doesn't come on if he's
watching tonight because he probably is
you know come on the show Matt Hancock
and maybe you put up a good defense for
all the stuff that I'd been throwing at
you in the last few weeks but I don't
share the nation's Joy at his
Rehabilitation because I think it's come
way too early I want to know the results
of this inquiry I want to know how
culpable he is actually as the health
secretary for all these people who died
not least all the thousands of people
who died in Care Homes because he sent
people back from hospitals without
testing them so to me these are really
serious things which I don't think
should be distracted in the way they
have been by him gallivanting with ant
and DEC
listen Pierce you you know the rights
are wrong for MP galavanting with ant
and DEC are the rules of the House of
Commons you know I think we that the
media love to say Matt Hancock killed
thousands of people the truth is he
didn't it was advisors who gave the
government advice but I would go on to
say is you as Piers Morgan don't think
he should have done it but you can't
fake votes and millions of people voted
for Matt Hancock in the jungle and
whether the media liked that or not
millions of people said we like Hancock
and millions of people said we want to
hear what Hancock has to say I'd say an
answer to your question about
his future going forward peers you know
if he chooses to now embrace the public
media in the public Arena he's got a
great platform because you know I guess
a bit like you he's Marmite what I mean
by that some loving some hate him but a
lot of people love him now
that's a new that's a new low even by
your standards
let me let me ask listen um
Scarlet you were knocked out before Matt
Hancock that means you are less popular
with the British public than Matt
Hancock I mean I don't know how you can
walk the streets with that hanging over
you
listen ultimately people were voting for
their favorites yes but I am so more I'm
so much less known than Matt Hancock so
people don't really know who I am I
think I went in there as the underdog
and I did my best that was the most
important thing so people aren't going
to vote for me I can't do anything about
that if they're going to vote for Matt
over me then so be it trust me I wish I
was there up in the final three but I
wasn't so I just know I did the best I
could do I came off there everybody was
proud of me my mum and dad and brothers
were proud and that's all that matters
really my parents said if I ever do I'm
a celebrity they'll disown me it's their
Red Line in the Sand uh but but thank
you both yes
one thing's for sure
Jonathan final word
before Scarlet went on the show this is
a big star on Channel 4 and she is a big
star of Channel 4 with her TV shows so
the one thing eye to the audiences know
is Scarlet's a big star in years to come
excellent I think we can all agree with
that and great to have you both you can
go back inside now it's not freezing
outside and braving your fans Jonathan
who turned out to be my fans uh but
thank you both very much indeed for
joining me I appreciate it all the best
[Laughter]
oh you gotta love it live TV uh well
coming next they call it the beautiful
game and this moment maybe proves it
USA's Anthony Robinson consoling Iran's
Ramin rezian after America's Victory
we'll talk about that more with my pack
next
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
guess who's got a brand new show on top
TV at nine o'clock Friday nights live
honestly I don't care I'm a bit rude why
just a bit of fun Friday night's live oh
I will be honest with you I'm not too
honest the criticize was so bad come on
Cristiano give it a chance well go on
then why is it not gonna work tell me
you have to be charismatic yeah well
people have to to feel some connection
with you to be good looking helps too
all right cheeky
football bloody hell Friday at 9pm
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I'm Tom Newton Dunn join me on first
edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today the first edition is about making
sense of what's really going on in
politics on the economy and across the
World At Large
it makes sense opinions that matter so
don't miss first edition with me Tom
Newton Dunn each week night at 10 P.M
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my fantastic pack is here associated
with the Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire talk
TV contributor Esther cracker I'm
political Sketcher out of the times
Quentin let's welcome to all of you
Quentin Royal race rail we've been on
this Rodeo you have yeah what are you
making this it seemed to me a sort of
significant moment because actually that
was a senior person in the Royal
household speaking at quite some length
it would seem in a really racially at
best insensitive at worst really
offensive manner a black woman you may
on the breeze hear the sound of cackling
and that's coming from Montecito I think
right where Megan and Harriet they will
be delighted by this I'm sure such as
their generosity of spirit I've got an
88 year old mother uh this lady hussy 83
yeah
something uh I find it hard to condemn a
woman of 83. and also
it might be a bit of a generational view
that that kind of questioning would not
to people of that age perhaps be as
obviously insensitive offensive as it
would be to people of mine or yours and
my grandmother has made similar mistakes
I've had like some 93 year old women
asking me how is your English so good I
was like I went to school
and they do make these blunders it has
happened if you had these conversations
with people a lot absolutely they say
where are you from I I there's a level
of Grace I have with it because for the
older generation it's not right and I'm
not making excuses for it but I can
understand that for them that's an
appropriate way of addressing it but
when someone asks me where I'm from for
instance and they're my age group I'm
like well I'm from Ghana right because I
clearly don't look Welsh to anyone so I
don't take offense to it I think it's
it's about how you approach it but I do
think in this particular instance she
was I mean I felt Kevin it was the fact
she went on and on and on yeah and
seemed to not want to listen to her when
she said I was born in I'm British no
that was to me the point when well at
least at that point shut up that's right
well when it's clearly racist I think
it's rude and it's snobby was it
malevolently done it's also it's also
corroborated by somebody else over
correct heard it was it was it
malevolent or we don't know what her
intention was maybe it is because she's
old but that doesn't mean it wasn't
racist it's a disaster for the royal
family because terrible for William and
Kate it's in a mile their American trip
it's perfect for Megan and Harry's
Narrative of absolutely leave the racist
royal family they're getting this award
next week I mean all of it is bad I
think for the Royals as they try to come
through all that yeah you could you
couldn't make the timing worse yeah for
them as opposed to William and perhaps
Charles's credit she's been frozen out
immediately yeah she's she's gone Quincy
uh Matt Hancock I mean he won't go away
he's like a boomerang you throw and it
just keeps hurling back at us I
literally bugged it that is the nature
of the man yes it is I literally bumped
into him and we had a perfectly cordial
conversation in which I said I've been
booting you around for the last few
weeks even though I know yeah and he
said absolutely perfectly phlegmatic job
done as far as he was concerned gone in
millions of people voted for him he came
third I mean quite extraordinary he's a
Tigger he's rubber yeah he bounces a lot
um should we admire that quality yeah
yes I think we possibly should actually
but I I don't want to I don't get I
don't think there's any interest at all
in condemning or saying he mustn't do
this or I mean I think there's a very
strong element of vodaville in politics
always has been and particularly it's
all theater it's well there's an element
of that yeah so definitely and you can
also you also have to acknowledge I know
you find this difficult to uh in this
case that the people have spoken yes no
no no I do I just think whenever you let
the British public make a decision you
end up with things like brexit if you
end up with Matt Hancock coming first
and you end up with the boat that was
named boating
what rule one never let the British
public vote on anything
yes absolutely president
they were having a laugh away weren't
they that's what they were doing and you
could vote up to five times so it wasn't
a true democracy it sticks in my gut
there's been no inquiry into the
pandemic which is at the moments him of
any of any bad mistakes or wrongdoing
fine I'll be the first to say it I think
you should at least wait no before the
rehabilitation talk I condemn him for
going and abandoning his constituents
you could have a bush took a bill in
Parliament to Outlaw such Behavior but I
think it should in the end be down
I think it just makes us take politics
less seriously I think him doing this
should have automatically triggered a
by-election a complete insult to the
public and I do think there should be an
inquiry into how he handled covert
because
we should have done this afterwards
before he before he goes launching a
picture of a toad on his head isn't
going to save him money you're a man of
words you're a great literary intellect
steady not least when you look in the
mirror
a greatest author British author of all
time none this is a new poll number one
Jane Austen two JK Rowling three Road
Dahl four Shakespeare five Orwell six
Tolkien Arthur Conan and Doyle C.S Lewis
Charlotte Bronte Emily Bronte where do
you sit with that who's your favorite
who do you think it's the greatest
Anthony trollope for me really PG
Woodhouse Neville shoot yes I would put
on there good call uh and how about inia
Blyton yes uh why not uh why not I've
told a lot of books and got a lot of
children I'm more of a I'm more into
poetry probably Barrett Browning yeah
and it's my favorite really yeah well I
would say yeah Dark Horse aren't you
don't remember these things Captain w e
John's as well I should have said
Biggles yes yes Charles Dickens is not
even in the top 20 best of times
yeah should we really should we really
move past Shakespeare that's the
greatest um isn't Shakespeare really the
greatest now when you think of what he's
brought around he's not Jane Austen's
number one right so he's got a good
thing in my he's the greatest would you
would you want to read I think he should
be well can you can you imagine you're
not involved in the debate by the way
yeah no one can see you you're up at
night with a pint and a half using a bag
of crisps yeah you really want to read
Shakespeare yes
are you watching the World Cup a little
bit did you see the scene like America
Iran a lot of enmity before the match
it's amazing moment where one of the
American players consoled a weeping
Iranian player it does seem to me the
World Cup is in a unique place to act as
a force for Unity and it should be
because it's a game isn't it yeah must
remember that this is the most popular
game in the world and when England won
the 22 Cricket the other day they all
raced onto the pitch afterwards and
started hugging themselves yes I would
have liked to have seen them uh shaking
hands I think that's the third point I
love the world cup and obviously you
know Donna doing well I know I can't oh
I'm so happy but obviously this match
with Iran and US was emotionally charged
because of what's going on in Iran so it
was really nice to see that camaraderie
and Kevin is he coming home
suddenly I don't think it is
excited as you are we do have a very
good chance it's not important I still
think Brazil I think then probably
France yeah I think Portugal can't be
ruled out but I think England have a
good chance it's nine goals without
Harry Kane scoring yeah yeah and you
know he will but he's been so creative
no no look football is always about Hope
isn't it you always who do you think's
gonna win World Cup give me your name
Hereford FC give me a name I I think
England definitely win it Brazil okay
I'm going Brazil actually Brazil if
Neymar's injury recovers if not I'm
gonna say Portugal on the record they
look good thank you to my pack brilliant
as always that's it for me tonight
whatever you're up to Keep It Uncensored
good night
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
guess who's got a brand new show on talk
TV at nine o'clock Friday nights live
honestly I don't care I'm a bit rude why
just a bit of fun Friday night's live oh
I will be honest with you I'm not too
honest the criticize was so bad come on
Cristiano give it a chance we're going
then why is it not gonna work tell me
you have to be charismatic yeah well
people have to to feel some connection
with you to be good looking helps too
all right cheeky football bloody hell
Friday at 9pm
[Music]
[Music]